مثلا رائع في الحب والعطاء ضربته زوجه
مصريه تدعى هبه عطيه بعد ان احدى زوجها
قطعه من جسدها هبه لم تتردد لحظه واحده
لانقاذ حياه الشريك حياتها بعد زواج 17
عاما رغم علمها منذ فتره الخطوبه باذابته
بفارس سي الا انها لم تتخلى عنه وتزوجته
انجبت منه اربعه ابناء لكن طول فتره
زواجها كان الزوج يعاني من ورم بالكبد
وقام باستئصاله لكن بعد العمليه تدهورت
حالته الصحيه جدا وحدثت تليف بالكبد رفض
اقرب المقربين التبرع له فاصرت الزوجه على
ان تتبرع له بجزء منك وجاءت انسجتها
مطابقه تماما لانسجته لتكون سببا في انقاذ
حياته لي يا شيخه معنا
[موسيقى]
مهما كان كل انسان امامه شخص بحبه الا انه
في عندنا انانيه نوعا ما انانيه ايجابيه
عندما يتعلق الامر بالابناء بنقول بنعطيهم
عيوننا لكن عندما يتعلق الامر بالزوج هل
فكرتي اكثر من مره وترددتي انا فكرتش ان
انا اتردد تماما
لان الزوج برده ربنا بيقول لو امرت على
الزوج ان تجد لاجدد لزوجها
فطاعه الزوج واجبه بالذات في حاله انقاذ
حياته من الموت
واعادته للحياه مره اخرى
طيب احمد انت طلبت من زوجتك بانه بامكانها
انه تتبرع ولا الفكره ما كانت بالحسبان
بالاول
ولا لانها كانت ضعيفه يعني شكلها كده
نحيفه
وظيفه وكنا الحاله بتاعتي كانت ميؤوس منها
وكنا بنقول ان احنا عايزين تبقى علشان
العيال
يعني تربي عيالها كنا خايفين عليها وكده
يعني
حتى العيله عندنا رفضت قال خلي انت انتهيت
كده
وخلي الوليه تربي العيال
لكن هي اصرت انها تتبرع
والحمد لله ربنا كلنا بالنجاح طيب احمد
انت لجئت لمقربين لالك ورفضوا ممكن تقول
لنا شو كان موقفهم شو كانت تبريرهم وانتم
كيف اتعملت مع هذا الموقع
ان الدكاتره بيتعلموا فيكم
وزرعاته خلصان وحالتك منتهيه خالص وتعبانه
[موسيقى]
لان الحاله الصحيه كانت تعبانه جدا
واستسقى كبير عالي
وصحه تعبانه خالص يعني لك ان تتخيلي مش
كنت قادر اكل حبات طعميه او شويه فول كنت
بروح مطعم الفول وطعميه ده اشم ريحه بس
لكن ما اقدرش اكل حاجه خالص صحيا تعبان
هي اللي وقفت جنبي بس لكن ما لقيتش اي حد
من القرايب ولا من هنا ولا من هنا ولا اي
حاجه خالص
لا ربنا ما يجيب اي خلاف ان شاء الله
وبعدين انا ما عملتش حاجه بايديا ده دي
كلها دي كلها تقدير ربنا وتوجيهات ربنا
[موسيقى]